from behind the arc here start to gain
why six of Orlando's 10 scoring
possessions have been three-point
possession says Terrence Ross frozen
down on another assist with Nicole Abuja
[ __ ] won't where to go deflection by a
be picked up by Ross shot clock it to
half-court shot by team ruffs from
midcourt
gives the magic the leaves aren't you in
front of him but picks up the foul then
here's what you want to do you want to
at least just get it so it hits the rim
at least so you give your chance another
chance if it goes in great the second
spouse gets blocked by Gordon
accelerating to the frontcourt gives it
to Ross he'll shoot for three he has 30
in the second hand Terrence Ross a
three-point shot and a foul three left
this is just a nice job curling around
that screen and curry Bradley blocked
from behind by Ross great effort
Augustin with the save three on one
butch if it's rolling down the middle
five minutes per game off the bench
averages nine per game for the Spurs
Terrence Ross Nick Vukovich now remember
the shot clock reset to 14 Terrence Ross
count it and the foul [ __ ] is all the
way down to five runs watch the screen
Ross wisent lost Wilson that's the quick
screen by Burch just to get a little
separation here comes the screen from
Gooch Terrence Ross firing
[Applause]
the cold-blooded
think there's nothing going on for the
magic shot clock going down Terrence
Rawls crosses back and rises up for this
what a terrific news to create space he
turns it over daily kena and easy steel
[Applause]
nice play bad turnover gotta do a make
up for it make a play on the other end
and terrific defense DJ crossover
nothing there laughs on the crime Tech's
it all the way magic take the lead 34
seconds to go
it's that part
comes in two Watts Watts looking for a
mocha the other name to rose up in an
Big Shot my parents rock on for three
point eight on the clock short clock got
to make something happen over the top of
the c'mon moody for one hinder Ross
one-on-one against Thompson Daleks for
three again he drills it right between
the eyes
Nancy Lanza there there's your answer
who wants taking flight by the plays of
the game Jeff Bernat rates
half-cut Maris Roth look at duck 51
successfully
chased off the three-point line balloons
hang there across set him up there's
still coaching people in the right spot
watch is wide open for three in the set
up and Terrence Ross I think he was
surprised how wide open he was when he
squared a little extra time to get their
paychecks messed up done
blocked by Ross in the final seconds of
the first quarter Bobby gets a phone
call to the CEO good play by Ross on the
deflection is the dunk
[Applause]
Ross again and a four-point opportunity
for Terrence Ross see if the man who
could stop it right here bunch of it
powers it down
play in the halfcourt boss looking for a
screen doesn't need much daylight rising
over morris get got it four days for
three boy lot of opportunities rough
with the steal at midcourt
[Applause]
to watch the great hands by Terrence
Ross kicking across the court of heaven
for da heads up Aaron Gordon coming
right down the lane
how about into your picture night
floater no good bunch of it's chips it
ties it they have the past arises and
throws it down we seen a lot more of
this with great job by Isaac getting it
out in front T flight pic you're right I
thought he took off just sending it
through 24 hooch
[Music]
the Baptist 14 wrought out on a
three-pointer but this is pretty good
too
chance for three the old fashioned way
the bump the leader
[Music]
Ross off the screen for breach well
that's a tough finish to traffic by
Nicole to boots a [ __ ] Terrence Ross
filled in for three Terrence Ross coming
off that ice cream back in that wind
[Applause]
extra pass to Harris spectacular play by
Terrence Ross into the play good
closeout look at Ross to get a hand on
that well that's not easy coverage once
you've never gone off the ground
Terrence Ross driving on partner not the
basket and a foul on Vince Carter's
elder like that good drive get the
contact and a soft floater and a try and
get Ross open the pass came off of Bombo
Ross picked it up and shot it in just
are you drawing up
[Applause]
Papa Terrence Ross for three deep drills
it
and Merry score know where he is at all
time
baba rejects saturated it's four on one
porter couldn't get there watch t ross
in transition a heck of a pass Aaron
Gordon delivering those long arms or
four ring span that will pour in that
game in Orlando from behind the arc
Russ beautifully executed from grant he
had to break turn grants perfect tax
break by the rim
Ross soaring in from the baseline side
[Applause]
steal by Ross he the head of the pack
26 back then look at the great still
there and then he is off and run runway
clear drop George great challenge by
perch and Gordon Ross stepping through
the middle raised in an around shrewder
for genetic the deck and at the other
end Ross finishing technical foul
objects Westbrook
Ross against Ferguson three-point shots
will support Terrence Ross putting
pressure on AG
bucho [ __ ] dr. Ross open for three big
shot by Ross to keep the magic to that
there Briscoe founded by Isaiah Canaan
Ross on the drive Christy of Washington
magic requiring bolts from the
Philadelphia 76ers parents Ross give him
two more from boots avenge stolen by
Wiggins and he is off and running
watches there what a play by Ross he was
out of bounds came back in and will be
Minnesota ball real look likes his
energy level likes it because it plays
made the basket
this is fouled on the shot counted it's
a three pointer and a fourth white
chance for Terrence Ross logician here
are we the Human Torch we'll be in the
starting lineup for Team be honest and
Nikola boots events will come Terrence
Ross parents giving a nice game is what
this is our flight of the game slam dunk
champion in all-star weekend 2013
Ross a dunk champion in Toronto days
before he won the championship in 2014
and hence Jodie Meeks
they do producer [ __ ] he makes the
right play down low to Ross the average
of all of my 28 for Terrence Ross
against his XD [ __ ] dude yep the last
minute of the game a steal by Ross a 1
dude he'll take it himself that he story
watch the great defense here at magic
doing a nice job is a terrific trap
force the turnover and off they come in
their sleep try by
[Music]
ference I'll be attacked pink scores
there what's wrong down the middle
finger rolls it in and the foul on
Indiana since what again kind of leaps
stretch is able to get his ballot
Ross count the basket and a fire first
two points for Terrence Ross 10 20
points per game his first day of the
night Carter Williams finds Ross that's
a good idea
[Applause]
hard to the basket perch a rebound
plenty of time left rush the buzzer
tears for a six-point play this is a
great job watch Kimber's turn realize
the team process is open get it right
back to him Ross same spot same result
he is at three prevent spot on the floor
bad Ross parents pull it up for three
relevant
[Music]
somebody forgets to pick up T Ross in
transition out of the corner for three
buzzer beating three by tier on Ross
driving on Galloway nobody their parents
hammers it in so the Collison and
turnerkn didn't that pick and roll each
way out on Terrence Ross nothing but the
bottom of the net if they on a pacer is
on fire medicine shoes on the floor you
almost want them shooting from behind
the arc
Terrence Ross thrills it 4-3 the human
torch on the ax trees all the way around
here's Carter Williams to watch to
cordon
hey guys four three
[Applause]
laughs Alicia he lies for three big
brilliant
Wow
watch firing
[Applause]
burglary passages two-parter
a young back for Atlanta John Collins as
well they swarm him
Ross Augustine back to Ross 9:25 or so
liver 1011 here in the second he's
already picked up that second lieutenant
of defensively right there
Ross passed Lowry in Sri Lanka
Department shark bath
Isaac swatted it away
Rossi's the clock it lets it go
[Applause]
the half the steel
core team it's a three-point game at the
break and Lando step back
tough free long rebound Ross
two minutes to play loss on the land and
it's a poker game
sentence married life is leaving up the
floor stolen plus one second phase
[Applause]
the guy you do not want to allow to get
going Ross ready for a big boy
[Music]
we founded to search
second trucks are behind by Terrence
Ross
let's go back to look at the blonde CT
whilst coming in from behind
[Applause]
[Music]
it's hard to tell he may have had an
argument dated with problem is what's up
you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content